first right first rank take two steps
forward
this is the nfac
armed aggrieved and increasingly visible
y'all know what our rules of engagement
are right we don't point out weapons
that nobody
unless they point them at you in an
america
where racial tension is raging the group
is exclusively black
and grandmaster jay is the closely
guarded
enigmatic leader he's agreed to speak
with us from what he calls
a safe house the group says that it's
not made up of
protesters or demonstrators that it is
a black militia and we're about to meet
the leader
grand master jay he's told us to come to
a secluded
location where he hopes we won't be seen
one of my jobs is to protect the
identity
of our members that is why i am the only
one that speaks for the nfac you have
folks that are veterans there are
corporate execs that are
members that don't want to have to deal
in their personal life
with the pressures of being a part of
this organization
we're going to prove to the world that
we can be just as organized
just as disciplined just as well armed
just as determined as any standing
military of any government
not as some mob in the streets that gets
together on the weekends to call
themselves patriots
why do you think it's necessary to carry
weapons
i'm not going to answer that question
unless you ask that question of every
other race that carries weapons
every other civilization that has gone
into other countries with weapons
the police carry weapons weapons were
invented to defend
oneself so it is only common sense that
we carry weapons
to defend ourselves it is not a question
it is a necessity
how would you describe the state of race
relations in america
right now pathetic there's no other word
it's pathetic it has deteriorated uh to
a to a place that is reminiscent
of the early 60s it is reminiscent of
jim crow
it is reminiscent of the the lynch era
it is reminiscent
of the days of the klu klux klan
there's a growing face-off between armed
groups in the u.s
but nfac insists unlike others they
haven't committed any crimes everything
that
that we've done has been within the
confines of the constitution
the day that the nfac steps over the
line it will be because the line was
already stepped over for us
first the black lives matter movement is
vast
and varied but he doesn't identify with
it
it has been infiltrated by people like
antifa
uh anarchists people who come in just to
destroy not to achieve
anything many in the very broad network
firmly reject that claim but one thing
the groups share
is a desire to end racial injustice
it is the aftermath and the incidents
themselves it's not just the fact that
they shot us
it's that once we're shot as in the case
of brianna taylor there's this feet
dragging there's this
lack of sense of urgency in louisville
kentucky they say they've helped
peacefully push for progress
a settlement for briana taylor's family
the 26 year old killed by police
and a grand jury decision now expected
imminently what if
the three officers involved aren't
prosecuted
what will your response be if they
decide they don't want to charge anyone
of course they've got to explain that
not only to the population that's there
but also to all of the other members of
the legislature
that have given this wide focus why and
if you can show us
in the law why you couldn't do that then
we have to live with that
others might not this is a year
dominated by confrontation
and this week could easily bring more
cordelia lynch
sky news